Speaker 1: Welcome back to the The David Pakman
Show.
My name is Jesse Dolma, and I would ask that
if you've been enjoying me guest hosting for
David over the last couple of days, the check
me out.
I'm at a dollar more.
That's on YouTube and Twitter and the rest
of them.
Anyway, thanks a lot.
So.
Mike Lyndell, the my pillow guy, his symposium
has been going on the last couple of days
and it has been a mess from the very start,
starting with the delay because they were
hacked to because, you know, he's got so much
incredible critical information for the American
public that people need to hack to get him
off off the rails.
Well, today was no different.
In fact, I've got a couple of clips here to
share that.
Really just to give you a flavor for the nonsense
and for the the the chaos that anything involving
Mike Pelo brings.
Here's the first clip of an absolute expected
moment where they're blaming technical problems,
of course, on conspiracy.
It's quite coincidental that the video feed
breaks and the light streaming platforms break
as soon as we start talking about this.
That, my friends, is a man named Ron Watkins,
Ron Watkins, who is thought by many to be
Kuis who ran eight Channe or one of those
other conspiratorial hate websites.
And he is is all but admitted on an HBO documentary
that he's que.
That's the kind of character and caliber of
individual that Mike Pelo, Mike Lyndell has
at this cyber symposium to uncover the truth
of Donald Trump's win in the 2020 election.
That's not all, though.
Get this speaker.
It really is just emblematic.
It sums everything up in the Trump era, exactly
how far down the rabbit hole people have gone
with their disrespect for expertize, their
disregard for truth and journalism and everything
that we should hold true in a free society.
Watch this.
Ladies and gentlemen, I'm
Speaker 2: not a computer guy.
I don't know what most of this stuff means,
but I've been researching this election since
November 3rd.
And I can tell you right now that everything
we're seeing right here, we saw in Antrim
County the adjudication logs being deleted.
It was absolutely censored by the media.
Most people don't know that this isn't anything
new.
We've seen it in Antrim County.
We've now seen it in Maricopa County, and
we're now looking at it with our very own
eyes.
And Colorado, what is Colorado matter?
Why are the attacking in Colorado?
We need to wake up as people and use the cameras
in the back there, not all of you, but the
concerns of the world.
You guys need to start reporting this and
stop fact checking it.
Speaker 1: And the crowd goes wild, the small
yet present crowd.
Did you catch some of those things that should
frighten you?
It should amuse you, but it also is there's
an element of cringe there that goes beyond
just that guy is a dumb ass.
For one.
He admits I'm not a computer guy.
I don't understand a lot of this stuff, but
I'm going to offer my unfettered opinion as
though it's qualified and then spouts a series
of debunked conspiracy theories that have
been led by the charge of have been led by
Michael Lyndell and Donald Trump and Lin Wood
and the rest of these purveyors of conspiracy
and propaganda.
And then that last comment should give you
pause.
Start reporting and stop fact checking, stop
reporting or start reporting, but please,
please stop with your infernal fact checking
it's getting in the way of our propaganda.
Unbelievable.
These are the times we live in right now.
If you thought it couldn't get any worse while
Donald Trump with president, it has absolutely
the train has jumped the track.
The Trump train has has has veered its careened
into a wall and now it is just in shambles.
It is a pile of twisted metal and carnage.
And this is what
we got.